un Ministerio Público particularmente
Clemente es el que vimos esta noche
entregando su Requerimiento con la
solicitud de penas para los ocho
acusados en este juicio por el atentado
del 14 de julio del 2016 en Niza y eso
fue justamente lo que decepcionó a los
demandantes Civiles para los cinco
acusados por infracciones a la ley de
tráfico de armas justamente que habrían
permitido al atacante conseguir las
armas solamente pidió la pena máxima de
diez años de cárcel para uno de ellos
considerado el creador de esta red de
tráfico de armas y de drogas en cambio
para los tres acusados por asociación y
lista terrorista para uno de ellos El
que además se exponía una cadena
perpetua le bajó la pena la solicitud
fue solo de 15 años de cárcel pues
Consideró que si bien Él fue quien
consiguió las dos armas que tenía el
terrorista hace 14 de Julio no podía
saber el uso que pretendía darle el
terrorista en cambio a los dos otros
también les pidió 15 años de cárcel para
cada uno de ellos pues si bien no
ayudaron a conseguir ni la pistola ni el
fusil de asalto si conocían la
radicalización del terrorista y podían
presumir el acto que pretendía realizar
esa noche en el Paseo de los ingleses El
veredicto este juicio se espera para el
próximo martes 13 de diciembre